and in turbulent crisis-torn times like
these
storytelling has always been essential
you see stories have a way to they can
change our hearts and our minds they can
help us
see each other in a new light jane
congratulations
such an honor you look
absolutely amazing i i want to ask you
this this award means so much
and you have done so much if your father
were here what would he say
if he were here to see you win this
award
well he'd be very proud of me he won
this award
and he'd uh i think so
i believe so um he'd be very proud of me
but i feel he is here i can feel his
spirit
hi jane i just want to know how are you
planning to celebrate
this amazing iconic win
well i am i'm i know where i'm gonna put
this already
and uh i'm gonna go home and then i'm
gonna go right to bed because i have to
get up very early in the morning
nothing too exciting but this is
excitement enough
i mean after all art has always been not
just in step with history but has
led the way so let's be leaders
okay thank you thank you so much
[Music]